[Music]
thank you
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show where it is my job to
deconstruct or at least attempt to
deconstruct interview shall we say
world-class performers from all
different disciplines my guest today I
feel for me has been a long time coming
I'm very excited to have on the podcast
Dr ghoul Dolan Dr ghoul Dolan is an
associate professor of neuroscience at
the Johns Hopkins University School of
Medicine and a Pioneer and world leader
of psychedelics research her laboratory
has discovered a novel mechanism that
could account for the broad range of
therapeutic applications that
psychedelics are currently being tested
for her lab has discovered a novel
critical period will Define what these
things mean for social reward learning
and shown that this critical period can
be reopened with psychedelic drugs such
as MDMA LSD psilocybin ketamine and
ibogaine building on this discovery
she's formulated the hypothesis that
psychedelics may be the long-sought
master key for unlocking critical
periods across the brain to test this
hypothesis she's initiated a nationwide
collaborative effort to determine
whether second reopen critical periods
for ocular dominance plasticity Birdsong
learning anatomical plasticity in the
barrel cortex serotonergic neuronal
regeneration dendritic spinogenesis and
motor learning and if you don't know
what those words or phrases mean don't
worry we will Define them as we go
importantly understanding psychedelics
through this framework dramatically
expands the scope of disorders including
autism stroke and allergies that might
benefit from adjunct therapy with
psychedelics an approach she has dubbed
the fathom project that's
p-h-a-t-h-o-m which stands for
psychedelic healing adjunct therapy
harnessing opened malleability Dr Dolan
earned her MD PhD at Brown University
and the Massachusetts Institute of
Technology otherwise known as MIT where
she carried out seminal work on critical
periods learning and memory and the
pathogenesis of autism you can find her
online at
dolanlab.org Dr Dolan welcome to the
show nice to have you thank you for
having me it's nice to be here so I
thought we might start with your
undergrad experience and I have read
that you designed your own major and I
was hoping you could describe how one
designs one's own major and how you
thought about going about designing your
own major
I've always been somebody who learns
best by comparing and I thought
originally I thought well I'll just do a
triple Major of Neuroscience and
Linguistics and philosophy and the
University was like no no we don't
there's no triple Major you can do a
double major but if you really need all
three we recommend that you
do this design your own major path and
so I worked with my professors in
philosophy and Neuroscience primarily to
come up with a curriculum that would
span all of the different elements that
I wanted to incorporate in trying to ask
the question you know what is the mind
what is consciousness how do we know
that from different perspectives and so
the major was called comparative
perspectives on the mind and it was a
combination of Neuroscience philosophy
Linguistics art religion
and really the idea was is that this is
something that humans care about and so
we've thought about it from all of these
different perspectives for Millennia and
you know what can we understand from
from that approach and yeah that's
that's basically what it was and how I
came up with it
why were those questions and hopefully
this doesn't sound like a stupid
question because at face value perhaps
they should be interesting questions to
everyone since on some level I suppose
Consciousness is fundamental but why
were these questions
interesting compelling to you at the
time enough that you would attempt to
have a triple Major you know I
or why exactly those it just compared to
everything else that was that I saw
other people majoring in you know like
economics or history I just didn't care
about those things the same way as I
cared about you know I just I just found
myself wanting I've always wanted to
only study or think about things that I
think are deeply interesting that I
would want to talk to with anybody
whether it be the person sitting next to
me on the bus or my parents or
somebody's kid I just like thinking
about things and when I'm obsessed with
something I just think about it all the
time in every context and so I just
never had that with economics or
you know history or any of the other
topics that seem to be popular majors
didn't cause the quickening
so
there are few terms that may come up
later we'll see it then I'd love to have
you just expand on them or Define them
because I was reading in prep for this
and you briefly considered marine
biology but you were also interested in
philosophy of mind and then
a philosophical consideration
called theory of mind what is philosophy
of Mind how should we think about it
what is theory of mind
philosophy of mind I mean
a branch of philosophy or anything it's
just a thing that
has drawn the attention of philosophers
from a variety of different perspectives
like
you can imagine considering what is the
Mind from a metaphysical point of view
so what are the things that we count
when we say this is what a mind is this
is what a mind is not
then there are other considerations like
well how do we know mind you know can we
know mind just through introspection or
is there some empirical way or some way
that we can compare different people's
descriptions of those things to get at
what is mine and that would be sort of
the more epistemological approach to
mine and I was interested in all of
those things there continues to be
debate about that and
one of the interesting ideas that I came
across was is that
there was this concept of theory of mind
which is not really a theory in like the
way that we have a theory of you know
light or a theory of synaptogenesis or
any of the more commonplace theories
it's more like it's a point of view the
shorthand way of explaining what theory
of mind is that I like to tell people is
it's it's sort of what you're doing it's
the neurobiological process that is
going on when you're playing poker you
know it's anticipating what somebody
else might be thinking and trying to see
the world from their point of view so in
some sense it's a theory about what
somebody else might be thinking and this
ability to understand or to have a
concept of what somebody else might be
thinking
it's something that you know we develop
and we get better at as we as we mature
so you can always tell when a kid is
starting to pick up theory of mind it
first comes on around age four or five
because they start doing these like
funny pranking behaviors where they'll
reach around your your back and tap you
on the wrong side and look the other way
and and that's them sort of playing with
the idea that their their own point of
view and the person who shoulder they're
tapping might be different and that they
can trick Somebody by playing on that
difference and so
this theory of mind
there was some idea out there you know
I'm not sure that it's really a dominant
Theory right now in in autism but there
was an idea that this is something that
people with Autism are not so good at
and it makes them bad poker players it
makes them bad at lying it makes them
bad at tricking people you know and it's
this thing that Psychopaths for example
are very good at they have better than
average theory of mind and they use that
better than average theory of mind to
manipulate people by anticipating what
they may or may not like and using that
information to try and get whatever it
is that they're trying to get and so
this this theory of Mind idea was sort
of out there and there was some idea
that well you need to have theory of
Mind in order to have Consciousness in
order to have a full sense of
knowing who you are compared to other
people and I like this idea because it
was a testable hypothesis and one of the
things that I found sort of frustrating
about being a philosopher is that
the philosophers were always asking the
coolest questions the biggest questions
but just felt like you know they were
just going around in circles and never
really coming up with an answer that I
found to be
deeply satisfying and on the other hand
scientists neuroscientists maybe they
weren't getting to ask all the really
big questions but man they were coming
up with some concrete answers that felt
tangible like we were getting somewhere
and so I like this idea that we could
test the requirement of theory of mind
for Consciousness by looking at diseases
where that function is impaired and
learned something about the relationship
between Consciousness and genes that
encode different proteins that are
required for that theory of mind
theory of mind
does not seem to be based on the reading
that I've done entirely human specific
and is it true that you have observed
this in for instance and you're tapping
on the shoulder made me think of it
hunting behavior in octopuses yeah so
those were actually not my my
experiments those were experiments done
by really
imminent octopus researcher Roy Caldwell
and he showed me the videos of them and
as soon as I saw the videos of the
octopuses hunting it occurred to me that
that is exactly a theory of mind like
behavior in an octopus and the reason
that that was so interesting is because
the way that people talk about theory of
mind is is that this is a behavior that
evolved due to the selection pressures
imposed by social living right so when
we when we have to live in a social
group it it serves us to be able to
anticipate what other members of that
social group might be thinking in order
to anticipate and
either compete or collaborate or
whatever it is that you're trying to do
and octopuses by and large are not
social species so you know if you put
two two octopuses of the same species
into a tank together they will kill each
other and there are you know differences
in the amount of aggressiveness that we
observe in octopuses some are so
aggressive that we've never even seen
the males of the species because they
basically when they mate they like leave
their hecticautilus arm which is their
reproductive arm in the mantle of the
female and eject it and Escape so that
they don't get eaten so we've only ever
found their hexagonalism that's how
aggressive that species is okay so other
species of octopus aren't quite so
aggressive but they're still asocial and
it was interesting because the species
of octopus that does that
hunting behavior is the only known
social species of octopus and so it was
it seems like an interesting opportunity
to test these ideas about you know what
are the selection pressures that make
theory of mind
develop across Evolution
and you know what are the species
specific advantages to having a theory
of mind but it's interesting also
because even though the larger Pacific
striped octopus which is the octopus
that does that hunting behavior is
social it's not using this behavior in a
social context that's using it in a
hunting context which suggests that you
know maybe theory of Mind originated
from a hunting Behavior where you can
imagine it would be useful
for the animal to be able to anticipate
where its food might hide if it was
being chased because you know octopuses
eat shrimp and fish and they're
excellent hunters and so the idea is is
that well maybe these ideas that social
behaviors are what Drive the evolution
of theory of mind is not quite right and
that it emerged by something earlier
like hunting Behavior
it strikes me as a hunter myself which
really only was adult onset hunting in
my 30s when I was writing about food I
felt sort of obligated to explore these
things that you would observe behaviors
that you could map to theory of Mind in
thousands of species that are really
effective hunters and I would love to
bring up three words that are in your
intro which I had read earlier that
people may not associate with the
conversation around psychedelics
currently autism stroke and allergies
where did your interest in autism begin
for me autism was something that I
became interested in
when I was an undergrad thinking about
these problems of theory of mind and
Consciousness because I was intrigued by
the possibility that you know autism
could be thought of as an impairment in
theory of mind and that it would be sort
of a case example of what happens to
your ability to have a fully conscious
experience in the absence of or in under
conditions of impaired theory of mind
and so how that relates to psychedelics
is really sort of a long-ish winding
story
which is that when I was a graduate
student my PhD work was focused on
trying to find a therapy for autism and
we had focused in on one specific type
of autism called fragile X it's the
first identified cause of autism it's
currently the most abundant
the most common cause of of autism is a
mutation in the fmr1 gene which encodes
fragile X
and what we had found is is that we
could
do a biochemical manipulation to correct
a cellular imbalance that in mice
corrected many of the symptoms of autism
that we could measure at the time and so
that was really exciting something like
26 other labs followed up on that work
and several big pharmaceutical companies
said okay this is it this is the
mechanism-based therapy that we've been
looking for and ran you know several
very large-scale human clinical trials
for that metabotropic glutamate receptor
modulator that we thought would correct
the imbalance in fragile X and when they
did those studies everybody was hugely
disappointed because we were expecting
the drugs to work and to cure the
disease and we really got very little
evidence to support that view and I
think at the time all the people who
were doing human research and clinical
trials were just willing to throw their
hands up and say well see we told you a
mouse is not a human and that's why the
trials didn't work because all of the
human trials were based on Mouse studies
and this was just where we went wrong
but a few of us kind of took a more
circumspect View and said well yeah okay
mice aren't humans but there were a lot
of other differences between the human
trials and and the mouse trials and to
me the one that really stands out is is
that while all of the mouse studies that
were done the clinical intervention the
you know alteration of the receptor
were given either right at Birth or a
Genesis or very early in development
whereas all of the human trials the
drugs were given to adults and it
occurred to me that because of the
timing of when the therapies were given
all of the mouse studies would have been
trying to correct the underlying
biochemical imbalance when the animal's
critical periods were all still open
whereas in the human trials the relevant
critical periods would have been closed
by the time we gave the intervention and
so the way that I'm imagining that a
psychedelic might be useful in the case
of autism is not to cure the primary
underlying problems with social
behaviors directly with psychedelics but
rather to pair the Psychedelic
intervention with the intervention that
we think is the restoring the
biochemical balance and when we do that
we feel like we can restore the
biochemical imbalance while reopening
the relevant critical periods so that
the the patient can learn from their
social environment in the normal way
under the conditions of the restored
biochemical imbalance
so I want to eventually ask you what
reopening the critical period looks like
chemically or neuroanatomically but
before we get to that I would love for
you to help me separate fact from
fiction with autism it's not a condition
that I know much about
and
I am nonetheless exposed to many
opinions about autism and people say for
instance that the prevalence is
skyrocketing that it may be caused by
people having children when they're
older or it's caused by God knows what
BPA you name it there's probably a
million different theories out there
and I would be curious to know as a
scientist what appears to be most
plausible as causes
of autism are rates increasing or are we
just getting better at diagnosing or
looking for that diagnosis Etc could you
just help give us the ABCs of fact
versus fiction
this is a great question and one that
I'm only going to be able to give you a
partial answer for because
things are are changing rapidly around
this so when I first started studying
autism you know 20 years ago
it was very narrowly defined as a
disease there was only five or six
different genes that had been implicated
in causing autism it was incredibly
highly inherited so you know if we can
give a heritability score for different
diseases and different inheritance
patterns hair color and eye color might
give you a heritability score of one
whereas something like cervical cancer
which is caused by a virus you know has
a heritability score of closer to zero
okay and autism had a heritability score
of something like .96 so very very
highly heritable and it made it
different from almost all of the other
Neuropsychiatric diseases out there
because
things like depression and anxiety or
hovering more around the 0.5 range so
sometimes inherited sometimes
environmental usually a combination of
those factors right and at the time that
diagnosis was so narrowly defined that
you got this high heritability and then
for a variety of different reasons some
of them scientific some of them
socioeconomic the definition of autism
got expanded and so there in the
diagnostic and statistical manual
of Neuropsychiatric disease the expanded
definition started including the
spectrum of autism and so now rather
than having you know you absolutely have
to have an impairment in social
behaviors and an impairment in locomotor
stereotypes and all of these other
developmental criteria it sort of got
expanded and and a lot more things
started being included and when this
happened
the
heritability estimates of the disease
dropped and so my interpretation of
those data is that basically we stopped
defining a disease that was a sort of
unified single disease and started
including a lot more things that were
not what I would consider to be
classical autism and so now it feels
like to me that this has gotten so
expansive that we're essentially
including things like
ADHD with social anxiety or all kinds of
other things that while they might be in
the realm of autism it makes it much
harder to identify it and say this is
what's being caused and as a scientist I
find this to be something that makes my
life much more difficult if we are no
longer defining the disease in a very
narrow way and so when this happens it's
a little bit frustrating and so I have
tended to focus on those early
identified genes like fmr1 which have
you know have been known to be a cause
of autism for a long time and more
importantly when we look at all of the
other genes that have been implicated in
autism so now we're somewhere in the
approximately a thousand genes have been
implicated in autism
fmr1 seems to be a node so in other
words the protein that fmr1 encodes
regulates roughly 2 25 percent of all
the other autism genes right and so to
me that's a good place to start to try
and understand autism and then I will
leave it up to the epidemiologist to
sort out how to redefine the category so
that we're capturing
the right subset of patients and
excluding the subset that are not going
to respond to therapy if we're targeting
the subset that are defined in one
specific way
if we look at fmr1 just as a node and a
focal point
I apologize that I don't know the answer
to this in advance but does that mean
that in the same way that if say a
couple were planning on having children
or someone were looking at
say surrogacy you could do genetic
screening that it's possible for people
to currently do genetic screening for
the probability of sort of autism as an
outcome and offspring
I believe I mean it's been a long time
since I was in medical school but what
level leave it was still the case that
fmr1 was rare enough that it wasn't
worth it to do the screening test to try
and find it because you know you have to
balance doing a screening test against
the possibility that the test itself is
going to cause problems with the
pregnancy
and so there's a there is a sort of a
judgment call there and unless you had a
family history of fragile X I think that
it was it's still the case that people
don't actually test for it beforehand
it's not like it's not like down
syndrome also where there's any strong
indication that
in Down syndrome there is a correlation
between the age of the mother and the
likelihood of getting down syndrome for
schizophrenia there seems to be a
correlation between the age of the
father and getting
schizophrenia but for autism as far as I
know there is no sort of age-dependent
correlation with your likelihood of
getting it and all of the causes of
autism are each individually so rare
that there's no screening test that is
generally applicable that would be worth
doing got it let's revisit as promised
the reopening of the critical period
the idea of critical periods first came
in 1935 By Conrad Lawrence who is a
ethologist who was studying imprinting
behavior in snow geese so this is the
behavior that shortly after hatching the
animals will form a long lasting
attachment typically to their mother
but if the mother isn't around and
instead it's you know sort of a
motorized airplane or the scientist in
that case Conrad Lorenz himself then
they'll form that attachment to that
other moving object in their vicinity
and you know there are all these funny
pictures online of Conrad Lorenz being
followed around by little snow geese
right because they form this attachment
wait what are snow Gees they're just a
type of geese you know like okay there
we go okay just wanted to figure out
sounds like a little Scandinavian dwarf
or something all right
okay so this is following around by
these birds they're really cute pictures
anyway and this imprinting Behavior
though if you wait so if you wait until
48 hours after hatching then they don't
form this Behavior right so this
attachment is only possible within the
first 48 Hours of hatching and Conrad
Lorenz called that period of time when
the animals are
extremely sensitive to their environment
and can form these long-lasting memories
he called that window of time the
critical period and critical periods
since then have been described for
so many different things so probably the
one that most people will be familiar
with is the critical period for language
learning so it's so much easier to learn
your first language that you learn as a
child than if you later on try and pick
up another language it's harder you
always have an accent it's not easy to
incorporate that into your first
language right and so that's a critical
period for language and what my lab did
is that we knew from the human
literature that there was probably a
critical period for social learning
right because we know for example that
teenagers are much more susceptible to
peer pressure than adults are we know
that they prioritize
learning from their environment from
their social interactions much more so
than adults do and that whatever social
environment you grew up in you know is
sort of your native social environment
so that for example when I go to Japan I
always feel like a bear in a China
closet because I feel like I'm always
insulting somebody without really
realizing it because I don't know I
didn't grow up in that social
environment right and so I don't know
that it's extremely rude to hand
somebody something with
one hand instead of two right like I
these are the kinds of rules that I
didn't grow up exposed to so it's it's a
foreign social language to me so we have
this intuition that there was a critical
period for social reward learning and
that's what my lab discovered so we
discovered that in mice just like in
humans there is this window of time
where the animals are learning from
their social environment much more
strongly than when they are as adults
right and we figured out a bunch of
different mechanisms relating to that
critical periods typically
the long long Arc of trying to
understand critical periods has really
been focused around this idea that
critical periods are great but the fact
that they close means that it's really
really hard to treat brain disorders in
adults because the brain is no longer
flexible and able to learn from its
environment in the same way as it was as
a child and so you know if we can
understand the mechanisms maybe we can
figure out ways to reopen them for
therapeutic benefit that's been sort of
the goal of Neuroscience for the last
100 years or so right is to try and find
that and three Nobel prizes have been
given for mechanisms trying to figure
this out because it's it's understood
that this would be so important but I
gotta say when I was a graduate student
this idea of finding the master key for
unlocking critical periods I never
believed in it and in fact my lab and
another Lab at Harvard were kind of at
you know in a intellectual debate with
one another over this idea of can there
be a master key and I was always like no
obviously anything that could do that to
the brain would either cause massive
Amnesia would cause seizures and
possibly could cause the whole brain to
melt and I was like there's no master
key stop it forget about it Harvard
you're just wrong okay and
and so what we've kind of come up with
now is we started with the idea that
well MDMA is sort of different from
other psychedelics in that it has this
very prominent pro-social component to
it right people take MDMA and they want
to cuddle they want to be sociable some
people you know talk about like the this
incredible feeling of empathy and being
able to see other people's pain it's
just a very pro-social type of
psychedelic in fact some people even
want to call it and pathogen rather than
a straight up psychedelic
and so we started with that idea that
you know okay we're trying to reopen a
social critical period we know it
follows a lot of the same rules as other
critical periods but maybe MDMA is the
way to do it and and in fact we did find
evidence that MDMA reopens the social
critical period and it does so by
restoring oxytocin metaplasticity in the
nucleus accumbens and we love this idea
that that was the story and other
psychedelics probably wouldn't do it
that was our original idea
but then again you know Mother Nature
tricky
so when we did the control experiments
to look at what other psychedelics are
doing we found that all of the
psychedelics reopened this critical
period even though nobody is taking LSD
and doing a 60 person cuddle pedal not
that I've seen anyway right the LSD is
not
prominently a pro-social type of
psychedelic
neither is I began neither is ketamine
and yet
all of them were reopening are reopening
this critical period for social reward
learning and so what this suggested to
me immediately was is that the whole
social part of the MDMA story was a
little bit of a red herring and that
really what psychedelics are are this
master key for unlocking critical
periods there's not just one critical
period there are lots of different
critical periods but
we are beginning to get a sense that
many of the critical periods close using
the same sort of governing principle the
same kind of molecules if not the exact
same molecules have been implicated and
the closure of say the visual critical
period or the touch critical period or
the motor critical period and what's
different is is that the social critical
period is kind of different from those
in that it's not a sensory motor it's an
emotional critical period that we think
is encoded in a different part of the
brain the nucleus accumbens which is
part of the limbic system it's a
different type of brain region than the
classical critical periods which have
all been defined in the cortex and so we
didn't know whether we don't know still
don't know whether or not the rules are
the same but what we did know what we
did figure out is is that when we did
RNA sequencing or genetic profiling
transcriptional profiling of what
happens to this brain region when we
give psychedelics and we reopen this
social critical period the molecules
that get up and down regulated in
response to psychedelics but not cocaine
share a lot of overlap in terms of their
molecular identity with the molecules
that have been implicated in
the closure of other types of critical
periods like Vision
somatosensation motor right and so
beginning to see lots of sort of
circumstantial evidence that the
psychedelics are all doing the same
thing they're reopening this critical
period and they're doing it in a way
that suggests that the social critical
period the social part of it is
irrelevant and that this is really
tapping into molecular mechanisms that
are conserved across all the different
types of critical periods and if that's
true then it suggests that these drugs
might be useful for reopening all kinds
of critical periods including the visual
critical periods including the touch
critical periods including the motor
critical periods and so that's kind of
the next direction that the lab is
heading is testing the idea that
psychedelics are fact this master key
for unlocking lots of different critical
periods
question back to autism and man must you
get a lot of questions about autism so
my apologies but I want to use that
example because and this will underscore
my ignorance in so many of these topics
but if we're looking at a narrow
definition of autism so we're not
succumbing to the scope creep in DSM or
elsewhere where suddenly everything and
its cousin is is autism but focusing
more on the fragile X
and that type of narrower more specific
definition when I then think of a
critical window
what is the interplay of the genetics
and the critical window when it is
untreated right when you don't have an
intervention does that mean that there
is a critical window but it's narrower
or for whatever reason
the child is less adaptive in that
critical window so it's not genetic
determinism it's not like if you have
this particular phenotype you're you're
destined to get autism and that you can
unwind the clock or rewind the clock in
a sense with potentially something like
psychedelics
to give them a second shot on goal I
know I'm asking this is probably a very
clumsy way because I don't understand
exactly why it would work but
why would reopening the window help
someone potentially with autism if if
they weren't able to capitalize on a
similar window earlier themselves
autism is a little bit complicated
because
multifactorial disease so let me just
give a different example to clarify and
maybe make it clearer why what we think
is the way that psychedelics could be
used for autism and that's with vision
right so one of the early observations
of critical periods is that if a child
is born with bilateral cataracts okay
and then
you remove those cataracts and they can
see but if you wait and you don't remove
those cataracts until they're age six or
seven then even though the physical
impediment to vision is gone
the brain cannot adjust to the visual
inputs anymore and so the child remains
blind forever and that's because there
is a critical period for setting the you
know strength of the synapses or visual
inputs and once that critical period is
closed even though the primary
impediment or the primary injury has
been resolved the brain can't
it missed its opportunity to wire
properly for the visual environment so
they'll be blind forever so the idea
there is if you miss the window and the
child didn't have their cataracts
removed until they were seven or eight
years old and you paired cataract
removal surgery
with psychedelics then the idea would be
that re if you know psychedelics can
reopen visual critical periods then the
idea would be that you would be able to
restore Vision because you would be
pairing the primary Intervention which
is the cataract removal surgery with the
reopening of the critical period to give
the opportunity to learn from the visual
environment in the natural way
and so with autism it's the same idea
we're saying okay there's a genetic
impairment that causes autism which we
think is related to an imbalance at this
one specific receptor which we can
correct by targeting that receptor but
if we just do that alone after the
social critical period has closed then
they still remain socially blind if you
will because we missed that window so
the idea is if we could pair that M
gluar therapy with a psychedelic then we
could restore the imbalance and
also restore the ability to learn from
the social environment so that they can
under those corrected conditions have a
shot at learning the ways of social
interaction the way they would have
during natural development got it thank
you that's very helpful and I I want to
just perhaps mention
that and this this is actually from the
microdose which is a great newsletter
you were featured in the microdose from
UC Berkeley
not too too long ago and
some people listening May wonder why we
shouldn't always leave our critical
windows open wouldn't that be great we
could learn everything and anything and
I just want to read something here and
then we can we can move on although we
could expand on it when you talk to
people who are on psychedelics it's like
hurting kittens they're paying attention
to everything look at this Leaf my shoe
won't fit Etc and they're in full
Explorer mode which is wonderful but
it's not very efficient habits get a bad
rep but you couldn't get out the door if
you didn't have them living in a world
where you're trying to learn and pay
attention to everything is emotionally
and energetically costly and
we can certainly expand on this but
needless to say
there is a lot to be said for a stable
version of reality with certain scripts
that run reliably is there anything you
would like to add to that before I ask
my my next question I would just expand
on that a little bit by pointing out
that
the reason that we have critical periods
at all rather than being sort of
genetically encoded with everything that
we need to survive in the world is
because the world is big and varied and
you know if you genetically encoded
everything you probably would be very
limited in what you could how you could
navigate that world right and so my
parents are Turkish if I was genetically
encoded with Turkish the fact that I
grew up in the United States would be it
would make my life very difficult
because I wouldn't speak English I would
speak Turkish right but because I have a
language critical period I am
genetically what's genetically encoded
is the ability to learn a language not
the language itself right that ability
to learn from our environment is why we
have them but
as
everybody knows right like being a
teenager sucks it's hard and it's
painful it's very emotionally draining
to constantly be checking yourself
trying to figure out how you fit in and
sometimes you want to just get on with
it and if the environment that you're in
is stable right then
you don't need to necessarily be
adapting or adjusting your model of the
world every single move that you make
and so that's why we think that critical
periods close but then another question
is why does the brain have a sort of
ready-made mechanism that psychedelics
can tap into for reopening critical
periods right like why can we reopen
them so easily if the brain wasn't
already built to do this and this is you
know really me speculating but I suspect
it's because when we
have these habits they're adaptive so
long as the environment is stable but
then there's a radical shift in the
environment then you can imagine that it
would be adaptive to be able to reopen
critical periods and relearn from your
environment so going back to the
language example you know as long as
everybody around you speaks English it's
probably not all that adaptive to be
learning Spanish but if you move to
Spain or you move to Central America
then suddenly nobody's speaking English
and you want to be able to learn the
language that everybody's speaking
around you and so we have a little bit
of other evidence that this deprivation
technique of reopening critical periods
which has been described for things like
the visual system the sensory system a
little bit in the motor system there's
evidence for this that this deprivation
induced can also reopen our social
critical period so here's another rule
that kind of applies across critical
periods is that deprivation is a
technique and so this might be the
explanation for example for why it's
easier to learn Spanish if you go to
Guatemala than if you go to Costa Rica
because in Costa Rica everybody speaks
Spanish but everybody also speaks
English right so it's very hard you're
not deprived of English you're just
exposed to Spanish whereas in Guatemala
almost nobody speaks English and so
you're you're deprived and you get the
language so that's one idea that we have
we don't we haven't proven it but the
other part of that is is that it's an
interesting to note that
historically religious practices across
many many different cultures have used
deprivation techniques to get to that
mystical state that people talk about
Zen Buddhists call it beginner's mind if
you were looking for a neurobiological
description of beginner's mind reopening
critical periods would be it right and
so what we think possibly is is that
remember how I said that I was you know
in as an undergrad I was really
interested in getting around to using
Neuroscience to answer the really big
questions that philosophers seem to have
exclusive domain for well this might be
it right it might be that if what it
feels like to be in that altered state
of consciousness or that mystical
experience that we think of with
psychedelics
is just what it feels like to reopen
critical periods then
this explanation this critical period
explanation gives us a mechanistic
handle to start answering those big
questions like well what is
consciousness well what is that mystical
experience what does it mean like to
feel and like you're an altered state in
the course of
my reading and feel free to correct
anything that I misstate here but part
of what makes
catalyzing pro-social behavior in
octopus is so interesting
with the use of say MDMA is that the
nervous system of an octopus and the
anatomical structure sorry as compared
to humans are so different right so in
humans we might attribute some of the
outcomes that we see or therapeutic
effects to I believe the nucleus Cummins
but then you look at an octopus Noah
Cummins no amygdala no default mode
network no pre-final cords
what have you gleaned from the octopus
work as it relates to
critical periods and or interesting
characteristics of MDMA
Tim I'm really glad that you asked that
question because I think that possibly a
lot of people in your audience know a
little something about psychedelics and
they've seen the studies where people
have been given psychedelics and they
take an fmri image and they point to you
know this brain region or that brain
region and say aha this is where
psychedelics are working and they get
this sort of warm and fuzzy feeling like
I understand now what's happening right
and as a neuroscientist I am susceptible
to that interpretation as well I don't
do it with fmri I do it with you know
circuit mapping and viral mediated Gene
transfer and look at it at a much higher
resolution than fmri Imaging allows so
my lab we do wholesale patch clamp
electrophysiology so we can do single
neuron resolution of these kinds of
anatomical maps of what neurons are
getting turned on by psychedelics and
from those types of analyzes we we get a
satisfying feeling like aha you know
MDMA is causing the nucleus accumbens
neurons to light up it's causing the
oxytocin neurons and the hypothalamus to
Fire and release oxytocin we got it we
understand how these work and I think
the really really compelling thing about
the octopus study and why so many people
who are you know not lay people just
regular scientists were a little bit
shaken by this octopus paper is because
it challenges that very comfortable
place that we've all been sitting with
circuit mapping that you know we have an
answer and what it says instead is is
that yeah okay those anatomical results
matter and they're telling us something
but they're not telling us the general
rules of how you build
complex behavioral functions from
synapses circuits brain regions and
instead what they're telling us is
something like the historical accident
or The evolutionary
byproduct of one animal's history of how
they came up with this solution but we
haven't really learned anything about
what are the generalizable principles
what are the motifs what are the rules
governing those
circuit level rearrangements that enable
complex Behavior
what are some other ideas in your mind
that that need challenging or that that
could be challenged just writ large in
in psychedelics
or psychedelic related science
I think the two big ones that I have let
me start with since we're since I'm
already you
people who do human research a little
bit let me just challenge the idea that
we can only understand what psychedelics
are doing in humans right that I think
for the last decade and the early part
of this one there has been this idea
that really the cool and interesting
part of psychedelics you can only
understand by studying it in humans
because humans are the only ones who do
the behaviorally complex enough things
that you would want to know about what
psychedelics are doing and I consider
Alexander Shogun to be you know an elder
in this field for me you know I met him
when he came to visit MIT I have this
goofy picture of myself you know is this
this young little neuroscientist all
like enamored of Alexander Shogun and I
think he was very much a proponent of
this view that like he needed to take
the psychedelics himself because really
the interesting part of what
psychedelics are doing you can only know
on a on a personal level and I I want to
push back against that idea because I
think that as we start to get a better
handle of what they're actually doing in
mice we may be able to come up with
things that generalize because after all
humans
didn't just emerge out of nowhere we
weren't plopped here on Earth by aliens
we evolved just like all other animals
on Earth and so we were subject to a lot
of the same rules and you know we came
up with some mostly overlapping
Solutions and some
some unique ones and so I think we will
eventually get to a point where we can
study the really cool and interesting
parts of what psychedelics are doing in
animals as well as
in humans and I think that our critical
period ideas one step in that direction
many people in your audience may have
also heard of the idea that psychedelics
are inducing plasticity and I'm very
careful not to use that word if I can
avoid it because plasticity is a word
that is thrown around a lot and it you
know means a lot of different things to
a lot of different people so for a
synaptic neurophysiologist it has a very
specific meaning
it's about the something that you can
record from doing
wholesale recordings or patch clamp
recordings or even you know unit
recordings in the brain but it's an
electrophysiological property that is
defined between two synapses
whereas the clinicians basically use
plasticity to mean anything that changes
over time which you know is so General
it sort of loses meaning and so I try
not to use that word as much as possible
and especially in the context of
psychedelics because
some people have tried to make the
argument that what psychedelics are are
so-called
psychoplastogens or
drugs that induce plasticity and this is
an inaccurate and confusing terminology
that I would really hope we could
abandon because there are drugs that
cause plasticity in the way that that
word implies
and they're all drugs of abuse so heroin
nicotine cocaine amphetamine these are
all psychoactive drugs that cause robust
bi-directional plasticity they cause the
neurons to sprout they cause the neurons
to shrink they they cause robust changes
and it's that very plastic or
hyperplastic property that we think
underlies their addictive potential
because that exaggerated sprouting or
that exaggerated plasticity we think is
what enables drugs of abuse to kind of
override the breaks on learning and
memory that are normally part of
naturally rewarding stimuli that allow
memories to be encoded in a way that are
driven by
limitations on Association so let me
give an example because I'm sort of
fumbling a little so the example I like
to give is is that a natural reward like
food for example we like food and if I
like a let's say a turkey sandwich I
might remember the memory that I formed
to a turkey sandwich that I just ate and
loved would be something like oh I love
that turkey sandwich next time I'm
hungry and I'm in this neighborhood then
I'm gonna go to that store and buy that
sandwich again I loved it but for drugs
of abuse we override those kinds of
associative constraints on when we want
the thing and you know we like
a drug of abuse like cocaine or nicotine
it sort of doesn't matter if you're
hungry or you're in the right
neighborhood or it's it's not out of
your way you just like it always and
that very ability to override that
constraint is what we think the
hyperplasticity is encoding and enabling
and making those drugs so much more
addictive and so I wouldn't want people
to confuse that property that
hyperplastic property with what we think
is actually happening with psychedelics
which is that psychedelics we believe
and you know they're starting to be
other evidence to support this View
are enabling what's called
metaplasticity which I know that it's
confusing terminology hyperplasticity
versus metaplasticity but metaplasticity
is an idea that's been around for over
20 years now that
says that the ability to induce
plasticity also can change over time
typically so when you're young your
ability to induce plasticity is is
greater than when you're older the
ability to induce plasticity declines
and there are molecular things that
control that So you you're mentioning
that plasticity can mean a lot of
different things to different people so
in this case the ability to induce
plasticity what does plasticity mean to
you in this use so the metaplastic
definition I mean it's a very specific
definition plasticity of plasticity and
in that case it was defined by
Mark bear and Cliff Abraham and it was a
synaptic physiology so it's synaptic
plasticity the change in response of
stimulating one synapse
and the magnitude of the response
changing when you're recording the the
post synapse so very narrowly defined
again so metaplasticity originally was
used to define what happens in the
reopening or the closure of the critical
period for ocular dominance plasticity
and it was defined primarily in terms of
the change in the subunit composition of
the nmda receptor which is one of the
receptors that's been so heavily
implicated in learning and memory and
specifically also learning and memory
with regards to visual processing
does that mean that ketamine would have
any particular applications to
studies involving visual processing I'm
just thinking given the it seems like
there's a decent
effect at the nmda receptor level with
ketamine when you look at chronic pain
and and other things is that the case or
is it not so much yes there are a
variety of things that have been
attributed to the nmda receptor for a
long time it was my favorite receptor
and here's why
I know it's super nerdy to have a
favorite receptor but oh I'm into it I'm
into it so nmda receptors are
fast neurotransmitter receptors but
they're not they're different from ampa
receptors which are the other major
subtype of glutamate receptor because
they have something
that basically the way the receptor is
designed is is that it's blocked usually
by magnesium and only when the neuron is
active or the the membrane potential
changes and the Magnesium no longer
wants to sit in there that magnesium
comes out so it because of that property
the nmda receptor is thought to be a
natural coincidence detector so it can
detect when two neurons are firing at
the same time and that has gotten
neuroscientists super excited about the
idea that this is exactly the type of
coincidence detection that would be
necessary at a cellular level in order
to encode memories okay and this idea
has been around for a while now it's why
people are excited about the nmda
receptor incidentally it's also thought
to be why ketamine and PCP interfere
with memory right so they do cause
impairments in memory because they mess
with the receptor that we think is super
important for encoding memories now in
terms of this critical period period
idea
nmda receptors they're made up of
different subunits and the composition
of those subunits changes over
development right so very early in
development The nmda receptors have the
subunit the B subunit is more
predominant and I the way I remember
that is that that's the nr2 B subunit is
for baby and then the A subunit is for
adults so as the brain matures then the
subunit switches out and it goes from
being to be heavy to being 2A heavy and
what that does to the receptor is it
makes it more or less likely
to be able to induce that synaptic
plasticity when the glutamate binds to
that receptor and that is the sort of
original first classical understanding
of what a metaplastic change would look
like it would be the change in the
subunit composition of the nmda receptor
that enabled the baby receptors to
induce plasticity more readily than the
adult receptors do
got it and just to try to recap my
understanding
which which will hopefully help the
audience track as well
jumping back to the autism example and
the fragile X or fmr1
the The Joint therapy
would look like using a compound such as
possibly a psychedelic to increase the
metaplasticity
followed by or maybe simultaneous with
the administration of the drug that was
so disappointing in human trials because
it was administered to adults
who had already switched to a different
dominant subtype
I'm getting close I'm not quite there
now you're very close and you're
actually sort of picking up on something
that is a hesitation I have about using
psychedelics and autism so there's
another a third type of
glutamate receptor that I love it's
called the metabotropic glutamate
receptor the M glue R and the
metabotropic glutamate receptor
we think is the one that whose signaling
is so altered in fragile X and the
metabotropic glutamate receptors are
also implicated as their brain matures
their expression goes down and so we
think that that
coincides with the closure of the
critical period and what we think is is
that in fragile X that and glue are
signaling is exaggerated it's kind of
not not being curtailed in the right way
and so we have some evidence to suggest
that autism might be caused by a failure
to properly close the critical periods
so even though theoretically I like the
idea of combining
negative allosteric modulator of the M
glue r with a psychedelic that can
reopen say the social critical periods
through metaplasticity in this case of a
different receptor I think in this case
it would be the oxytocin receptor that
would be the relevant one
I am a little bit hesitant to jump into
human trials for that without first
testing the safety of this in in Mouse
models because again there's this
tension between there's some idea that
the pathogenesis of the disease is
related to a failure to close the
critical periods properly so I'm not
sure that reopening them later is going
to be necessarily the right way to go so
you know it's still I bought this as
that we're testing
how do allergies fit into this
I've become very very interested in
allergies and all sorts of
not to paint with two broader brush sort
of autoimmune questions specifically as
related to
psychedelic compounds how do allergies
fit in
well first
premise this by telling
telling the immunologist and she hates
this idea
so we far over this and you know we have
we have the relationship between the
immune system and the nervous system she
basically lives in an immune-centric
world where the nervous system is just
like a downstream effector of the immune
system which is the primary controller
of everything and obviously I think it's
the other way to wrap
so the idea with allergy is this like
there is some epidemiological evidence
to suggest that allergy has a higher
prevalence in countries where the food
and the water is largely parasite free
and so that part of the immune system
which is ordinarily
used to fight off parasitic infections
is left jobless so the idea is is that
in that state of joblessness it sort of
goes out looking for another threat to
fight against to protect the body
against and in this formulation I am
thinking well what if how that threat
gets assigned is really through the
brain the brain is saying okay well that
dog is barking at you
and your immune system is left jobless
that's threatening go and fight against
the dog proteins right if that's true at
least in a subset of patients with
allergy then you can imagine that
reopening that learned sort of threat
that critical period for the Learned
threat of you know that's misassigned
would enable people to unlearn the
association between dog and Allergy now
that that's a very different way for
example of looking at it than
the way that some people focus on
psychedelics to think of it as they have
these anti-inflammatory properties which
I think are true
independent of this critical period
explanation and
that property might be beneficial in
allergy sort of independent of this this
learned Association
framework that I'm proposing
around the critical period so we just
don't know yet I like the idea though
because there are a few anecdotal
stories of you know I think Andrew Weil
has a story where he cares himself I was
going to bring him up
cats yeah and I love the idea because I
actually kind of wanted to be a
veterinarian but I'm allergic to horses
dogs and cats so you know I would love
to take psychedelics and cure myself of
those allergies and while I love this
idea I don't believe it enough yet to
you know take a bunch of psychedelics
and go snuggle up to a horse like
because I think you know we could be
looking at anaphylactic shock in that
situation so I don't believe it yet but
I like the idea as something that we
could test
okay so yeah I'm glad you brought up
Andy and not the sole example I mean I
have and understanding the plural of
anecdote is not data but nonetheless
sometimes helpful for generating
hypotheses this is something that's been
in the
in the conversation with with numerous
anecdotes for a while and I guess what I
want to ask next is whether it's autism
stroke or allergies and I do want to
come back to stroke when we are talking
about reopening critical windows and
in the introduction in your bio that I
read we had MDMA LSD Soul save and
ketamine and ibogaine which
act on quite a number of different
receptors LSD seems particularly
promiscuous maybe I began as well but
broadly speaking are we talking about
increasing post-synaptic
sensitivity in which case they could be
hitting different receptors
but as long as it's eliciting that type
of
sensitivity that is associated with
earlier critical Windows it fits the
description of reopening the critical
window is that so let me back up for a
second and just explain that there's
sort of a debate going on in the field
right now if you look back in the
textbooks written in the 70s and 80s
about psychedelics you know textbooks
written by people like Solomon Snyder
who started my department at Johns
Hopkins and discovered almost every
neurotransmitter receptor you've ever
heard of including by the way the
serotonin 2A receptor
their definition of what a psychedelic
is was very broad right so they
basically said it's anything that causes
this altered state of consciousness
altered perception of time space body
self these were all sort of things that
psychedelics do and they included
psychedelics ranging from ketamine PCP
all of the class what people are now
trying to call the classical serotonin
psychedelics like LSD mescaline
psilocybin DMT and then also the weird
ones like MDMA and ibogaine and and you
know both Snyder and Alexander Shogun
considered all of those drugs to be
psychedelics more recently there has
been this push mostly led by the
chemists to say oh no no no no if we
look at the receptor binding properties
of these drugs the classical
psychedelics the hallucinogenic
psychedelics they're all serotonin 2A
receptor binding and even though they're
promiscuous even though they're binding
to a bunch of different receptors
the Psychedelic effects seem to be
mediated by this receptor using you know
pharmacology studies in humans and they
are really pushing hard to kind of
exclude MDMA and ibogaine and ketamine
from the definition of classical
psychedelics but I personally feel that
this is putting the cart before the
horse because we don't know that that is
necessarily a good boundary for
defining psychedelics first of all
because we know that most of the
psychedelics are very promiscuous in
their binding second of all we don't
really understand whether or not the 2A
receptor is required for the therapeutic
properties right so there is some
evidence that there are anti-depressive
properties that may or may not be
blocked by serotonin receptor
antagonists there's two papers that have
exactly opposite results about this
right now I am not entirely convinced
that those anti-depressive properties
that they're measuring have anything to
do with the durable context-dependent
long-term therapeutic effects of
psychedelics that we see in humans and
so I think it's up for debate whether or
not the serotonin 2A receptor is
required but what we do know is is that
psychedelics that have primary binding
at nmda receptors serotonin Transporters
serotonin 2A receptors Kappa opioid
receptors ones that span the diversity
of receptors all show some therapeutic
effect right and so our lab has really
been focused in trying to understand
well what's the commonality across all
of those receptors and so to kind of in
a long-winded way get back to your
original question
what we wanted to know is what's
Downstream of those receptors that's
common to all of those psychedelics and
we don't have the complete answer yet
but the answer that we're coming up upon
is is that it's not the receptor it's
not even one step Downstream of that
people have been excited about the
possibility that changes in biochemical
signaling at the level of beta arrested
might be the next step after the
receptor that might be common we don't
see that to be the case in our studies
and what it seems to be is Downstream of
that even more which is
regulation of the extracellular Matrix
which we think is sort of the final
common pathway that happens and the
working model that we have
is that psychedelics sit get bind to
their receptor and when they sit in that
receptor for too long
it signals to the cell oh no oh no
excited toxicity is coming
hit the reset button and what that does
through a variety of different
mechanisms is we think and we don't have
a strong evidence to support this but
this is our working model is is that
that hit the reset button involves
calling in all of the receptors
internalizing them cleaning up the
synapse degrading The extracellular
Matrix that is sort of holding the
synapse together and the last step of
making a synapse mature and stable and
that sort of hard reset is enabling the
reintegration of those baby receptors
that are more sensitive and able to
induce plasticity that's sort of our our
working model
hmm
so I'm curious
just to revisit Kappa opioid for a
second because the only Kappa opioid
Agonist that I'm familiar with is
Salvador and a some people may know
Salvia divinorum which from a
phenomenological perspective to get real
fancy subjectively people find it
typically pretty dysphoric and I'm just
wondering how
perhaps it's not Salvadoran but any
Kappa opioid Agonist might be used
therapeutically what applications might
exist I mean people have been excited
us because it's sort of thought to be
like that's going to be the one that's
going to make you not be addicted to it
and it's not very pleasurable but
because that's for sure because it's not
very pleasurable you know nobody wants
to take it I don't want to overstep the
Kappa opioid stuff the reason that we
got interested in it is because the IB
gain also has high affinity for Kappa
opioid receptors but it also acts as
serotonin Transporters so I really don't
know what the answer is there I I
thought the beta arrest in story was
gonna nicely sew everything up and it
just didn't what is beta arrested I'm
going to plead ignorance I don't know
what that is basically most of the
Psychedelic drugs except for ketamine
and PCP are acting at what are called
g-protein-coupled receptors okay so when
I was talking about nmda receptors
versus m gluar receptors the difference
is M glars are are G protein couples
receptors and nmda receptors or ion
channels so they're inotropic receptors
right so metabotropic inotropic it has
to do with how they're coupled to
internal signaling so all of the G
protein-coupled receptors including this
almost all of the serotonin receptors
they they work by when the drug binds to
their binding pocket they induce a
series of biochemical events either
excitatory or inhibitory biochemical
changes Downstream
that are sort of the second messengers
if you will of the receptor binding okay
now that's just how they normally signal
but when a drug like LSD binds to the
serotonin 2A receptor
you know Brian Roth's group has shown
that when it sits in its receptor it has
an unusually long off rate so normally
when when transmitters get in their
receptor they jump in and they jump
right back out so they pop in pop out
really really fast okay less than a
second time scale LSD when it sits in
the serotonin 2A receptor binding pocket
a little lid kind of comes down and
locks it into place and when that lid
locks the LSD into place its off rate
goes to four and a half hours which is
like insane gonna be a long night it's
gonna be a long night exactly so
so and that's the half off so only half
of it comes off in four and a half hours
right and so this was like a really
important insight into why it is the
lsd's effects last so long but when it
sits in that receptor for too long
instead of signaling through the normal
G protein coupled signaling path way
what happens is it starts sending signal
to the cell no instead of G protein you
need to hit a different biochemical
pathway we need to trigger beta arrested
and beta arrest is just another
biochemical pathway that gets triggered
by that receptor being activated too
long and what is thought that beta
arrestin does is rather than do the
second messenger signaling it says to
the cell pull that receptor out we're
about to get toxic damage from too much
receptor Activation so beta arrest and
signaling historically has been thought
to be a signal to the cell that says
pull in The receptors right and so I
really loved the idea that even though
not all psychedelics bind to the
serotonin 2A most of them
you could imagine a scenario where they
were triggering beta arrest and
signaling over G protein coupled
signaling and that if you knocked out
the beta arrestin protein that you could
block the ability of psychedelics to
reopen critical periods and while that
was true for some of the psychedelics it
turned out not to be the universal
mechanism that spans across all of the
psychedelics so that was a little bit of
a bummer I have to say because I thought
all right we'll solve it it'll be done
and you know it can rest easy but it
didn't work out that simple Mother
Nature always likes to trip us up like
that so the mother nature curveballs
seem to come more often than not
I do want to get to strokes and how they
fit in but before we get there I have to
scratch an itch because I've been
wanting to ask you for a while now
first a bit of background you mentioned
Alexander shulkin also known as Sasha
Shogun for people who don't recognize
the name
incredibly Adept incredibly prolific
biochemists
very much recommend people check out
picol and tcall
which which he he wrote with his wife
but
the contrast you drew earlier was one of
say maybe human centricity so he not
only created or resurrected hundreds
maybe thousands of different psychedelic
compounds but also was a very dedicated
self-experimenter and the tasting
parties were very famous of course where
do you most strongly perhaps agree or
align with Sasha what are things that
you perhaps have in common
if anything comes to mind
I gotta tell you a funny story of when
he came to visit MIT when I was a
graduate student it was sort of the
opening party for the new building and I
won't name any names but there were you
know everybody had invited a bunch of
Nobel Prize winners who had discovered
you know every cool thing in biology and
they all got up there and not
necessarily knew anything about
Neuroscience they were all sort of older
and they kind of gave a little biography
and then sat back down and then Sasha
got up on stage and he was just
basically the same age as everybody else
the only person without a Nobel Prize on
that stage and yet he was so alert and
so Adept and he was like oh and then we
added this methyl group over here and
this happened and you know the
behavioral response and then we did this
and we got ego this and we put that on
there and all of the neuroscientists
were just like wrapped attention right
because
this is it like this is what we all
dream of as neuroscientists is to have
some manipulation that we can give in
this case a drug that is dramatically
altering the way that the brain is
functioning and interpreting the world
around it and here is this chemist you
know sort of explaining to us how this
could be done just by adding a methyl
group in this position versus that
position and we were all just like blown
away I don't think there was anybody who
walked away from that lecture thinking
gosh you know psychedelics should just
stay in the back Waters we shouldn't
care about this as Neuroscience
obviously not right and in fact it's how
I got excited about Neuroscience to
begin with I took this class when I was
an undergrad called drugs brain and
behavior and in that class the first day
I saw the photograph of the molecule of
LSD sitting right next to the molecule
of Serotonin and the similarities
between them I was like this is it this
is how we're going to crack it this is
how we're going to get at those hard
questions of Neuroscience because here
are chemicals that can alter
our entire sense of reality
Consciousness perception time self space
everything right and I am not alone I
think most neuroscientists who have
tried psychedelics would have exactly
the same response and the difference
between me and Sasha really in terms of
our approach is is that Sasha comes from
an older tradition in science which was
very much prioritized the sort of
do the experiment on yourself idea and
that has a long and glorious tradition
in science for example we have a cure
for
ulcers because there was a biologist who
was convinced that those were caused by
a bacteria but nobody believed him so he
drank a vial of bacteria gave himself
ulcers and then took a bunch of
antibiotics and cured himself of the
ulcers and he won the Nobel Prize for
that right the difference is with
psychedelics is that that's a little bit
trickier to do right because
psychedelics have this property which
William James you know pointed out over
a hundred years ago of creating this
sense of
what he called the no edit property this
feeling that now that I've had this
experience I know the really Real the
true truth has been revealed to me and
everything before this moment was just a
facade or some lesser truth or some
limited
access to the truth but now I really
know and so for a scientist that's
pretty dangerous right for a scientist
you always want to be able to have a
little bit of skepticism about what it
is that you have discovered you always
want to keep your ideas as sort of
provisional until the next test comes
along until you know it should always be
a working model never uh this is the Ten
Commandments of Neuroscience right we
just don't that's not the way that we do
science and so the noetic property I
think does mean that that that
experiment where you
take a bunch of bacteria and give
yourself ulcers is a little bit
harder to justify in this psychedelics
so that's that's how I
hard to be an objective or strive to be
an objective scientist if you turn
yourself into David koresh accidentally
so how do strokes fit into this
for a long time now clinically we have
known that
right after you have a stroke you have
this very short window of time you know
kind of
really really close by three months but
really you want to get in there within
six weeks to two months or so
where physical therapy is going to have
its maximal effect or benefit for
helping you to recover the motor
function that you lost because of the
stroke okay and that window of time
we don't exactly know why it closes but
it seems to be that it's not that the
damaged part of the brain suddenly
re-sprouts neurons it's that the brain
regions immediately adjacent to the
damaged part of the brain become
flexible again and able to
perform or control the motor functions
that were lost by the the brain region
immediately next to it okay and that
window closes
just like all other critical periods
close and so far the best way that we
have for reopening that critical period
is to give another stroke but nobody
wants to cure Stroke by giving another
stroke right so that's just not a
clinically useful way hard to sell hard
to sell that yeah definitely even harder
and so we're we're sort of we like the
idea that maybe
we could Branch out into other critical
periods like this one
to see whether or not psychedelics can
reopen that critical period for stroke
and we have a collaboration with Steve
zeiler who's a neurologist at Johns
Hopkins who has developed a rodent model
for
that that critical period of motor
recovery following stroke and he also
has a stroke clinic at Hopkins and so
we're working closely with them to see
whether or not this idea really
really can help these patients which
basically it's a 400 000 patients a year
in the United States who have
debilitating lasting impairments because
of stroke so it's a it's a huge number
of people and if this ends up being true
it's super exciting because here's
something that we started out with oh
I'm just curious what MDMA will do in an
octopus it was totally curiosity based
science and to see it evolve into
something that can potentially help so
many people is
as a scientist
just super gratifying it's pretty rare
nobody really gets to have those kinds
of woohoo success stories and so that's
very gratifying to me on a personal
level but also I think that for all of
the psychedelics enthusiasts out there
it's a lesson in how important it is to
never stop learning never stop
questioning you know I think there was
an intuition a few years ago that well
indigenous people have been using
psychedelics forever we don't really
need to understand their mechanisms we
don't really need to dig into how it is
these things work because we know
they're going to work because they've
got this long history behind them but I
think that if this ends up being true
that this mechanistic explanation can
really open up whole new avenues that
people hadn't been thinking of before
then I think that that's a testament to
the importance of always keep an open
mind always look for more answers more
questions and keep searching
absolutely and I would also say even if
let's just say hypothetically these
various indigenous cultures have figured
it out let's just take that as an
assumption for a second they figured out
how to use these things but the scale at
which they are used and the context
within which they're used are on the
order of say Max 100 or several 100
people within the safety net of certain
rituals and familial and social support
structures that it cannot be replicated
at scale in say a western treatment
Paradigm you need new tools right and
that requires exploration and
and testing let me just Riff on that for
a second because I think that that's a
really important point about the context
right so the context of disease is also
different in this culture versus other
cultures and how a disease is defined is
different in across cultures and how you
might approach a disease is defined
differently across cultures and so a
good example is the way that ibogaine is
used traditionally you know in these
cultures that using ibogaine for
traditional healing practices it's not
just that the person taking it is has a
disease and they're being treated it's
sort of a mix between they have a
disease but they also have something to
share with the rest of their community
and the whole ibogaine experience is you
know
encapsulated in a bunch of things that
we as Western doctors might dismiss as
just ritual but include things like face
painting and social touch and the whole
Community is involved for this three day
long trip that a person goes from one
house to another right and it turns out
that a lot of those elements that we
might not necessarily recognize as
important that we might dismiss as
ritual
in a mouse we can recapitulate right we
know that mdma's ability to reopen the
social critical period is social context
dependent right if we give it an
isolation then it doesn't reopen so it
turns out that there are all of these
elements that go beyond just the
molecule and we can't just import take
the thing that we decide is the most
important element the molecule and
import it into our medicinal practices
and our cultural history without
understanding it because many of those
elements of the ritual might be actually
really important to how these drugs are
working therapeutically and unless we
understand it from our context we won't
be able to readily adapt them I think
100 and to maybe clarify the point I was
trying to make somewhat inelegantly
I think all of these practices are worth
studying especially the things that have
had some degree of longevity and
persisted over time that seem to be
adaptive or could potentially plausibly
be helpful in the therapeutic effects
and
I push back maybe it's because I'm in
Austin and you can't throw a rock
without meeting someone who did a you
know Weekend online course and is now a
self-proclaimed Shaman so I have a
certain sensitivity to it but this
romanticized I think very naive notion
that you can just copy and paste things
whole cloth from one area to another
is not just naive but also quite
dangerous and I appreciate you saying
what you just said if
you flash forward in your mind I
recognize there's some imagination and
speculation required here but if this
this critical period work and maybe the
offshoots of that work continue to gain
support through rigorous science and
evidence
what might therapeutic
interventions or treatments look like
10 years from now I'm pulling that
number kind of out of nowhere but I'm
curious to know sort of in your mind's
eye what you think things could look
like if this if this continues to
develop in the direction that
at least now you're pursuing research
I think for me if this ends up being
true then it's gonna be a pretty big
paradigm shift for Neuropsychiatric
treatments because
and let me just back up and say I have
to give a little bit of credit to Maps
here because Maps did a lot of really
hard work to convince the FDA that the
way to design clinical trials around
psychedelics was to abandon the sort of
one variable at a time test model and
say look we really need to pair these
drugs with Psychotherapy because the
drugs are not doing the Magic by
themselves it's really this this
combination that's working and so that
that I think was a a big shift in the
way that the FDA wants us to test drugs
in clinical trials and I think that
we're beginning to see more and more
evidence that that context is really
what matters so for example the clinical
trials where context is sort of
secondary where the Psychotherapy is
essentially
there in case somebody has a bad trip
but it's not really front and center to
the intervention then I think those
trials for psilocybin for example aren't
working as well as the trials where
it's really seen as an adjunct to the
Primary Therapy which is the
Psychotherapy now if we're right and the
critical period reopening explanation is
this
shift in the framework for how we
understand these therapeutic effects
then in 10 years from now the way that
psychedelics are going to be used is
going to be trying to identify that
right context for the right disease
right so while an interdirected trip
with a lot of psychotherapy makes a lot
of sense for PTSD and addiction and
depression it's probably the wrong
context for stroke right whereas doing a
lot of physical therapy and movement and
playing virtual reality motion games
might be the right context for giving
the Psychedelic for stroke
you know for allergy maybe the right
context is snuggling up to that horse or
that dog or that cat that you're
allergic to right and so I think the the
future the therapeutic potential for
this is going to be the opportunity is
huge but the devil is going to be in the
details in terms of
identifying the right context and
figuring out how to get activation of
the right neural circuit that's relevant
for the sort of brain transformation
that you want to see happen
if we take the case of stroke patients
for instance if we just
assume for the moment that we're using
human subjects
how might you think about
currently
what type of experimental design you
would use with respect to dosing because
if you have this less interdirected
say
a higher dose experience with the
potential for
these nomadic qualities that you
describe but rather you're following
instructions you're practicing skills
using potentially VR
give any thoughts on on how you design
the study or what the minimum effective
dose might look like
so so there are two questions in there
let me just
pull dose issue that we've done so far
suggests that there's a pretty narrow
dose response for reopening critical
periods it matches what we see in humans
for the acute subjective effects but we
don't see any evidence that
increasing the dose necessarily
increases the opening of the critical
period or how long the duration of the
critical period open state so basically
what we find is is that if the acute
subjective effects are short like with
ketamine then the window only stays open
for a very short amount of time like
less than a week whereas if the acute
subjective effects lasts a really long
time like with ibigain which lasts 36 to
72 hours then the window the critical
period window stays open for much longer
in mice that's four weeks and humans
that make translate to four weeks or
four months we're not sure but it's not
the case for example and then you know
psilocybin MDMA and LSD are in the
middle there between those two extremes
but it's not the case that if you double
the dose of LSD then you can get LSD to
open the critical period longer for
example and so that dosing business I
think you know is going to be a little
bit of a heartbreak for all all of the
pharmaceutical companies out there that
are essentially trying to engineer out
the Psychedelic Effects by shortening
the duration of the of the Psychedelic
effects to you know get less side
effects and a shorter Journey that will
be easier to manage in a clinical
setting and again what can you do nature
is nature but I do think that it changes
the model of how we approach these
rather than thinking of these as Next
Generation anxiolytics or next
Generation
anti-depressants or ssris what we really
need to be thinking of these as is more
like surgery right like who wouldn't if
you have a heart attack you go and you
have open heart surgery it lasts for
eight hours
you have maybe two or three weeks
afterwards where you are required to be
on bed rest and take things easy but
then you're cured right and so who
wouldn't rather be cured of you know a
heart attack than have to be on a
medicine for the rest of their lives I
think most people see that as the major
promise of psychedelics so in terms of
the therapeutic approach I think
the way I'm framing this stroke trial is
really like I'm not worried about the
fact that they're going to have to do a
psychedelic and potentially the maximum
benefit is going to be from these
long-acting psychedelics because I think
that you know these motor critical
periods are pretty strong closes and so
you want to reopen them
for as long as you possibly can to get
the maximal effect and we'll have to
work out the how to do them back to back
to back but that's sort of how I'm
thinking about it there
the second sort of thing I want to
unpack about your question is is that
you mentioned for the stroke that you
were imagining that we would be giving
the Psychedelic and the person would be
practicing a bunch of things in a very
specific directed way and actually
that's not how I'm imagining that this
will work I got it it would be more
sequential not concurrent no no no it
would be concurrent but I would say it's
not going to be practice based so one of
the things that I would want to
emphasize is part of the reason that I
paired up with
Steve zeiler and and John krakauer at
Hopkins is is that their approach for
treating
stroke during the normal well the
critical period is already open right is
that they've said well you know most of
the physical therapy that patients
receive is very goal directed right it's
I need to learn how to zip my pants with
the other hand I need to learn how to
comb my hair with the other hand and so
it's very much practical
you know solving the problem another way
whereas the way that we learn those
motor patterns when we're children is
much more sort of goal undirected kind
of play wandering
don't care if I fall down a million
times I mean there's this great idea
that
children walk when they're learning how
to walk we'll walk the equivalent of
seven football fields in an hour
now the only time I've ever seen an
adult do that is on MDMA right they will
just dance and they don't care if they
look like fools they don't care if
they're not good dancers it's not goal
directed they're just enjoying the play
of doing the motion right and so what I
like about Steve and John's approach to
motor Rehabilitation sort of without
psychedelics is that their virtual
reality system that they've built is
very much capitalizing on this non-goal
directed play-like behavior and I think
that's going to be the key and so I
think if we can get people on
psychedelics plus put them in this play
motor play contacts then we can
maximally
recapitulate the conditions that we
learn how to do motor function when
we're developing as children
So speaking of fun
I want to
go back in time to Bear's Lab at MIT and
this is from Spectrum news
reading a section of this he had
stressed the importance of science being
fun and the the quote is if you lose
sight of the fun in science it's hardly
worth continuing end quote he used to
say Dolan decided that if she was indeed
going to give up a life of science she
would go out on her own terms so could
you unpack that last sentence were you
considering giving up a life of Science
and then how did that lead to octopuses
because
it seems like that
Focus then opened up Pandora's Box in
the most positive way right so I want to
go back and sort of do a
do a little bit of postmortem on on what
exactly happened so
please uh if you wouldn't mind just tell
the tell the story of that period
when you start your own lab you get a
bunch of money and that startup package
is great to kind of get you started hire
some people buy some equipment you know
get your lab established without having
to worry too much about the funding when
I started my lab I got a nice startup
package I immediately got a couple of
private Foundation grants which were
very helpful to help me establish the
lab but you really can't in Academia
survive unless you can also get funding
from the NIH right and these big NIH
grants
have in my career in my lifetime have
gotten harder and harder to get and it
used to be that people who were young
and had a lot of creative ideas were had
much higher success rates than people
who were older and kind of just redoing
the same experiments with a very
conservative kind of rinse and repeat
type of experiments and over my
scientific career I have seen that
situation essentially reverse right so
people over the age of 65 are getting
most of the NIH grants Junior people are
really struggling and there have been
some attempts to correct that but they
just haven't worked and it's just
incredibly difficult to get funding
and then if you add on top of that
the funding has gotten so conservative
that basically the way that I write NIH
grants right now is like once I have all
of the results for that are going to
make a cool nature paper I write a grant
on all of the sort of boring experiments
that I didn't do it for that paper but
that I think that
somebody the reviewers might ask me for
and I package that together and I send
that to the NIH that's how conservative
my grants really are when I apply to NIH
funding and that's been successful but
it there was a moment sort of a few
months before the octopus paper before
we even did that experiment where I was
just beginning to feel like you know I'm
not gonna make it like I can't I applied
I applied to the NIH 17 times before I
got my first NIH Grant wow and I think
part of it was because I was proposing
these crazy ideas that people were like
there's no critical period for social
behavior what nobody's ever gonna use
psychedelics clinically what no that'll
never work oh you made those mice too
bad you didn't use them for the
experiment that I would have used them
for you're just a you know Junior person
you have no established track record no
no no no no no no no no and I was
feeling really
demoralized and I was like I I can't do
this like I thought I was becoming a
scientist because I was gonna get to
pursue these big questions and be
creative and steer my own ship that's
what I had worked so hard for as a
graduate student as a postdoc as a
medical student that's that was the the
dream that I was sold and I was pretty
devastated by how
many rejections I got
and so
in that moment when I was like all right
I'm gonna try a couple more times but if
I don't get it that's it I'm out my
department was very supportive they're
like you'll get there you'll get there
you'll get there we'll cover you don't
worry don't fire anybody you're good but
still like it's a bloatier ego if you
can't convince your peers at the NIH to
give you that money right and so
going out on my own terms I was just
like look I've always wanted to study
Evolution I've always wanted to do
something to do with Marine Neuroscience
I have this opportunity to look at what
happens to this behavior in an octopus
I'm just gonna go for it and it'll be
fun and even if
it doesn't work even if it
is not useful for my career in any way
at all like I mean I would go to these
meetings with you know the faculty
meetings and meetings with my department
chair and I tell them we were planning
to do this octopus stuff and he'd be
like cool what are you doing we hired
you to cure autism what is this octopus
stuff like what
and I'd just be like look you gotta back
off this is what I want to do this is
what's going to make me feel like
science is fun like I'm doing it not in
a goal directed way in a kind of playful
just out of curiosity I just want to
know what happens
and and then it worked and it revived my
sense of play and joy and feeling like
you can do those crazy experiments that
everybody thinks are crazy and have fun
with it
so you
I wouldn't say bet the farm but you were
willing to go out in sort of a blaze of
of glory and meaning just
focusing on fun and trying to break new
ground it worked
how do you think about if you do sort of
preserving that
type of
willingness maybe the octopus work kind
of bought you a golden ticket to now
continue to do work that is not rinse
and repeat but perhaps I'm just spinning
a story here but like I can imagine as
you get more established maybe you feel
like you have more to protect so maybe
there's an inclination to take fewer
risks how do you think about risk taking
moving forward
don't want to oversell how big of a risk
it was for me to do that experiment we
were already working on MDMA we already
had you know reasonable
response from nature about the MDMA
critical period experiment the octopus
thing was really kind of like well we
had the MDMA around and I've always been
curious and I just wanted to see what
would happen and then a collaborator was
like whoa we have seven octopuses that
we can lend you for you know a week and
I was like come on down he flew down he
slept on my couch you know we stayed up
until like two o'clock in the morning
every night like just doing it mad
scientists because we had to send the
octopuses back by the end of the week
and you know it's just like this mad
scientist fun time right and so
you know how do I preserve that well I
guess
part of I think the reason that we as
scientists are seeing less and less of
that kind of crazy stuff is really the
funding I mean the funding like I'll
just just to give
a sense of this I think this is a really
missed point and especially with tech
right so
in the 50s and 60s the NSF the National
Science Foundation and the NIH were sort
of funding all kinds of crazy stuff that
they just never thought would ever be
useful or have a goal they were just
funding it and so when you know Thomas
Brock was like there are these weird
bacteria that live in these thermal
vents in Yellowstone National Park give
me some money to go figure out how they
can survive those temperatures
NSF was like yeah sure here you go and
if he if they hadn't given him that
money the PCR test that we all learned
about during the pandemic would not be
possible because that enzyme that is
required for that test is made by those
bacteria that live in those weird
thermal vets right and so I think this
non-goal directed curiosity based
science
it doesn't show any usefulness for 40 50
years right so it takes that long for
something meaningful to come out of that
kind of Discovery based curiosity-based
science right and I think that the way
that funding constraints and the way
that the sort of
Tech and even private foundations are
very goal oriented right it's like well
how can we sell this how can we Market
this how can we and and you know the
private foundations have names like cure
autism now they're very goal directed
and I think that that sort of kills the
motivation or the impetus to just do the
weird stuff that's just for fun and
curiosity and I would say every person
who becomes a scientist
at one point or another had that as
their motivation and the strain of the
funding crisis is essentially what has
forced people to get more and more and
more conservative and so I don't think
I'm unique for wanting to just see what
happens when you give octopuses MDMA in
fact I think the reason that everybody
responded to that paper so well
worldwide is because every single one of
us has that Curiosity has that I wonder
what would happen you know and and it
resonated with people and I just think
it mostly gets beaten out of us because
of funding constraints
is there any solution there I mean if
you could wave a magic wand
are there any structural changes that
would help to alleviate that I'm just
wondering if anything comes to mind
aside from just like come on guys we
need the exploratory stuff the weird
stuff otherwise we're not actually
investing in the long-term Serendipity
that has produced all of these
these world-changing Technologies aside
from just like having drinks with people
at NIH or NSF or elsewhere and having
this conversation are there are there
other levers that could be pulled or
other changes that could be made
I would say that
this is sort of venturing off into
politics which is
a hobby not my area of expertise but I
would I would certainly say that if we
look at the percentage of
taxpayer money that well first of all
in the 50s and 60s
you know we collected a lot more taxes
today we give away more in tax breaks
than the entire discretionary budget
back to Big corporations as incentives
and tax breaks but really most of those
corporations
the thing that they are making and
selling right now especially in the tech
industry really
are possible because the taxpayers in
the 50s and 60s made those investments
in
the Science and Technology areas to
develop all of the Computing and
software
building
science and research that that stuff was
was built upon right like
Facebook and
all of these Tech Ventures that we and
Google and cell phones and computers
they didn't just tap into arise out of
America for no reason they came because
the United States for years understood
that this was an investment for the way
way future and so I think changing our
tax structure to sort of reinvest in the
future of science
it's either gonna happen or it's not
it's going to move to other countries
and you know places like China that are
investing in
science and technology in this sort of
non-goal directed just throw money at it
and eventually something cool will pop
out
attitude
I mean that's just my two cents so yeah
how about an insult like half your
audience but no that's that's what I
think I don't think you've insulted half
the audience but I think I I do I think
I mean I do think it's important to say
that the priorities of
the the government and nation state
affect
so many different components of life and
the future of
innovation in this country
and if you do look back as you mentioned
to the end of many of the innovations
that came out of say DARPA and other
organizations that were
fundamentally funded by taxpayer dollars
I mean it's it is remarkable to look
back at how fundamental many of these
technologies have become Switching gears
I just ask a few more questions do you
have any books that you have shared
recommended or gifted the most to other
people or or recommended often to other
people any favorite books that come to
mind
how did we wander into this political
sphere
um probably the ones that I have gifted
the most is a book called invisible
women By Carolyn creado Perez I really
love it because I think it's a book of
feminism that is that is accessible and
I think resonates with people whether or
not you're a man or a woman right it's
it's just data it's like all right well
here's how much it costs to keep
ignoring women and if you fix it your
city can save a million dollars a year
right like it's all about the structural
stuff it's not about your feelings about
whether women deserve to
be in the kitchen or not it's not about
that it's just here's how ignoring data
about women's body sizes women's travel
patterns you know ends up costing
Society at large and I think it's an
excellent way of kind of getting that
and then the other book that I love the
most it's called the dawn of everything
a new history of humanity by David
Graber I actually love everything that
that guy wrote I started with this book
called
[__] jobs which you know I was
dealing with like the bureaucracy of
Academia and feeling very frustrated and
I read that book and it was very
cathartic and then I just kind of went
down the rabbit hole and have enjoyed
all the other books but the the dawn of
everything like it's a big book and it's
pretty thick
but the last chapter has some really
cool stuff about
psychedelic uses in
in other cultures and then
the third one that I really love is the
immortality key
by Brian moresku I I love that book so
much like I designed my entire Halloween
decoration this year all around that
book and you know I I send pictures of
it to Brian and he was like oh my God
you nailed it I gotta up my Halloween
game so yeah that's those are the three
books that I would recommend yeah the
mortality key is the only of the three
that I've read but fantastic book really
really exceptional and
it has made me want to try to meet
archaeochemists and have more
conversations about recreating the
elixirs of Midas and many others so
we'll see if I ever get around to that
if I have to maybe cut back on my
podcasting to make time for that
well I
I love book also
turkey and
intentions is Ephesus which is an hour
and a half drive away from my mom's
house and
you know I'm definitely next time I go
to Turkey I'm visiting Ephesus to try
and figure out all those those Hecate
you know carvings and maybe take a
little soil sample just a little soil
sample Customs love soil samples
so cool this this has been a wonderful
conversation we've covered a lot of
ground is there anything else that you
would like to add any closing comments
anything we didn't discuss that you'd
like to make mention of or draw
attention to before we wind to a close
for at least this initial conversation
oh God I can't think of it I think this
has been one of the most fun Meandering
conversations I feel like we covered
everything I look forward to doing it
again sometime
because I really do think that in the
next few years we're going to have some
pretty
pretty ground shifting stories coming
out and I would love to come back and
share them with you absolutely things
are moving quickly things are developing
quickly and I think we're going to have
a lot of very exciting interesting and
provocative questions on the Forefront
of Science in the next few years which
I'm looking forward to and I'm glad that
you are very willing and capable of
challenging
the maybe dominant beliefs or the
beliefs to get traction and are willing
to take risks with the the science that
you pursue so thank you for doing the
work that you do and is the best place
for people to find
your work dolanlab.org is that where you
would Point people yes
yes perfect well thank you for taking
the time today
oh wow excellent pronunciation thank you
yeah I love turkey I love turkey the
language I'm fascinated with that's a
conversation for another time very
similar grammatically to Japanese oddly
enough which is where I've spent more
time but I really appreciate you taking
the time today and being willing and so
game to explore so many different
subjects and to everybody listening
we'll have links to the various terms
stories people names books Etc that we
discussed including studies in the show
notes as always at tim.log podcast and
until next time experiment widely be
just a bit kinder to yourself and others
than is necessary and thanks for tuning
in